- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy
and I just wanted to remind you
that if you're in the position to do so,
to think about making a
donation to Khan Academy.
We are a not for profit organization
and we can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
And now, as we are approaching
the one year anniversary of
schools in the United States
and actually schools in much of the world
having to shut down physically
because of the pandemic,
it's even more that we
double down our efforts.
Obviously, during the school closures,
many, many, many folks leaned
even more on Khan Academy.
It was the place where they went
to make sure that they kept
pace with their classes
or if they weren't
getting distance learning
that they were able to get their learning.
But now, as we're starting to see
the light at the end of the tunnel,
I've talked about this very publicly,
we really have to view this
as a disaster recovery effort
because so many students,
most students arguably,
have accumulated all
sorts of learning loss
over this past year.
Some students have fallen
off the radar completely.
And so, as we go into the
end of this school year
and actually the next several years,
we need to make sure that there
is free accessible resources
for students, for parents,
and for teachers and school districts
to make sure they can personalize
to the needs of students.
And as you can imagine, that's exactly
what Khan Academy is focused on.
We had over 12 billion learning minutes
on Khan Academy in
2020, and we expect that
that will only accelerate
in the years ahead.
That's 12 billion minutes
of learners around the world
really being able to
dig in into their gaps,
make up for any unfinished learning,
and then learn at grade level or beyond.
So if you're in a position to do so,
the social return on investment,
the social benefit to cost ratio
for Khan Academy is off the charts.
And so hopefully, we'll
make both your heart
and your head feel good about the impact
that you will have on millions
and millions of learners today
and billions of learners in the future.